nous allons donc nous attarder quelques
instants sur cette situation à lui dénie
la formation centriste lancé par
jean-louis borloo prend ses marques et
afin de s'offrir un peu de visibilité
dans l'ombre de l'ump elle commence à se
structurer vendredi soir les jeunes
adhérents du parti ont lancé leur propre
fédération dans les yvelines
le reportage de catherine de l'atome lui
dit en marche depuis le mois de
septembre et avant même que le président
départemental soit élu le 6 juin
prochain lui des jeunes se met à son
tour en place autour de deux
coanimateurs le but rassembler largement
des jeunes centristes aux jeunes
démocrates en passant par les radicaux
la gauche moderne où l'alliance
centriste en ligne de mire les
européennes et les municipales de les
municipales comme une formation jeune en
politique c'est une école de la vie
politique donc l'idée à travers un parti
jeune c'est former les jeunes à cette
activité citoyenne donc effectivement on
va avoir une vraie volonté de placer le
plus de jeunes qui sont investis et
implantées dans des communes sur des
listes pour commencer à appréhender le
débat le débat local des jeunes ont
aussi des idées à faire valoir
surtout quand on voit que la crise
économique touche particulièrement les
jeunes
on va aussi d'autres moyens moi je pense
que ce qui est important à mettre en
avant c'est aider l'entrepreneur
l'entreprenariat des jeunes donc aider
les jeunes à monter l'entreprise avoir
confiance en eux et de se lancer
première réunion ce vendredi soir à
versailles entourés de leurs aînés à
l'image de pialat guérinel première
adjoint amour pas venu délivrer quelques
conseils conseil la ténacité les échecs
du moment ne sont pas des échecs sont
des obstacles qu'il faut surmonter
particulier les premières élections
bien peu de colère il faut être un peu
en colère ne pas accepter le monde tel
qu'il est ça c'est aussi le bon
carburant
en attendant de se mettre en colère lui
dénient jeunes d yves l'ena cherche à
rassembler actuellement la fédération
compte une vingtaine d'adhérents et
pourrait proposer des débats en
septembre
toujours concernant à lui des mises à
mort pas cette fois-ci georges mougeot
socialiste ne présidera pas le prochain
à un prochain conseil municipal de la
ville le 6 juin il est absent depuis le
début du mois d'avril pour cause de
maladie et c'est son premier adjoint
justement pierre leguérinel udi ancien
modem qui assure l'intérim
présent vendredi vous l'avez vu au
lancement de la fédération des jeunes
dei
il s'explique sur son nouveau rôle on
écoute pierre leguérinel cette situation
est claire le maire a dit lui même qu'il
avait quelques soucis de santé il entre
en convalescence il sera là à la rentrée
et pour l'instant la mairie fonctionne
elle fonctionne pas au ralenti comme
j'ai pu le lire
elle fonctionne pas loi impose qu'il y
ait un
une délégation pour que les fonctions
soient assumés en quelle leçon et la
ville tourne d'ailleurs la meilleure
preuve en est je crois beaucoup de mort
d'asia ne savait pas et ne se rendre
compte absolument de rien donc c'est
plutôt la meilleure preuve qui est que
les choses tourner correctement
c'est une situation qui est humainement
problématique mais pas politique au sens
de la gestion de la ville
ça n'est pas un problème et comment on
sent dans la peau d'un maire non non
attendez
d'abord il faut pas mélanger les rôles
c'est pas un maire c'est un maire de
droit c'est pas un maire politique parce
que ça n'est pas celui ci qui a été
choisi donc il faut que chacun reste à
sa place fasse le job
en attendant donc il faut faut éviter de
prendre la grosse tête ça sert à rien
mais il faut faire les choses
correctement
pire le guérinel qui sera invité sur ce
plateau lundi prochain pour revenir sur
la situation de cette ville de morteau
nous évoquons aussi forcément les
municipales avec lui et sa candidature
qui semble aujourd'hui plus que jamais
une évidence